hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear show where we talk about horror
movies
now as i said this month i'm just doing
random ass movies because there had been
a lot of stuff that had come out uh you
know on shutter and various other
streaming services that i wanted to
watch and catch up on without having to
worry about fitting them into a theme
and this was a movie that a couple
people had recommended to me now this is
a shutter exclusive as far as i'm aware
it originally came out in 2021
and it's called hellbender
now i didn't look too much into the
background of it before i started
watching it but the minute i started
watching it and saw the woman uh playing
the mom and the girl playing the
daughter i was like oh this is the same
family that made the movie the deeper
you dig
um which me and tom talked about
probably like a while back
so if you don't this is like so cool to
me
uh they're called the adams family with
just one day which i think is super cute
so there's three of them uh with you
know extended family also uh so john
adams is the dad and then toby poser is
the mom and then they have a daughter
named zelda
and they basically collaboratively
write direct edit
uh do the costumes do the music do all
the stuff for their own movies so
they're like a little family
movie-making collective and i think that
is so so awesome
so um i think that i remember like when
we talked about the deeper you dig which
was actually quite awesome um it's very
surreal
this one has a similar vibe to that but
it's considerably less surreal but it
does have the kind of
weird imagery and stuff like that that
the deeper you dig had as well
uh so if you liked that one then you'll
probably like this one too and i really
like that they're explained it's a
completely different story than deeper
you dig this one is a lot more
witchy demony type
situation so it's that kind of thing
where i feel like the um where the
deeper you dig was more like a murder
mystery ghost story type thing um but
more surrealism but yeah so i think it's
really really cool that this and like i
said what a time to be alive you have
like a little family and they do pretty
much everything like they make all their
own movies and
they seem to be kicking ass i mean these
movies are pretty damn good i have to
say for as a presumably low budget as
they probably are
so hellbender i've seen it compared to
the movie raw uh that french film
and i didn't get that but once somebody
said it i was like oh yeah maybe i guess
i see what you're saying um because what
it is it's basically sort of
like a coming of age like a girl coming
of age type story like coming into her
own power type of thing i think that's
sort of what they were talking about
like why it was similar to that
but so what you have
is uh the mom who i don't think is ever
named actually i think she's just mom or
mother
um who's played by toby poser the real
life mother of the daughter in this
now
she lives with her daughter izzy played
by her real life daughter zelda
and they live in this kind of farmhouse
on this really really isolated mountain
now we find out through the course of
the story that mother
has basically told izzy that she can
never be around people ever because she
has a really rare like immunodeficiency
disorder
so it seems that up until this point
this hasn't really been a problem
because they actually do seem to have
like a really good relationship with one
another they have a little band together
like a two-person band called hellbender
and they play little gigs they have
costumes and they play little gigs like
in their thing and actually the songs in
this are actually quite good they sort
of reminded me of sort of like 90s indie
rock or like riot girl type stuff
uh you know like i don't know maybe like
breeders or something like that in that
kind of area so yeah so i'm assuming
they wrote all their own music for this
as well but i just think so that's like
one of the things they do to entertain
themselves they're also
make a living uh or they eat actually by
foraging so they basically go out in the
forest and they're vegetarians and you
know they they just kind of eat plants
and whatever it is that they find out
there
now as i said this seems to be a good
situation now the mother does actually
go into town to get things because yeah
it would be hard not to and uh izzy
draws you know so the mom will go and
get her new charcoal pencils or a new
paper like new drumsticks or whatever
but izzy always once she gets older she
gets like a teenager she's kind of like
hey can i come to town with you and the
mother's like you know that you can't do
that you know you're sick you can't be
around people so that's basically what
she tells her but obviously izzy is
getting to a point where she's like why
can't i be around people this is like
you know she's like i love my mom and
it's fun out here with her but you know
i i need friends my own age and [ __ ]
like that there's also i mean there's a
prologue that basically says that this
is going in a which direction because
there's like a woman and she's being
hanged and they hang her and then
everyone's kind of standing around
watching but then she like comes back to
life essentially and then somebody's
like trying to shoot her and it doesn't
work so she can't like die so you know
that this is with some witchcraft is
going on
and that becomes more apparent too like
while
mother is in town she's buying some
stuff at a store and like this really
old guy sees her and says gosh you
haven't aged a day or something like
that like you um used to be the nurse
from my grandmother or something like
that and she's all like oh you know you
must have me confused with somebody else
or whatever so you know that there's
probably something supernatural going on
here
now uh so the little idyllic thing that
they have going on like up on this
isolated mountain farm
is interrupted
by like one day izzy is out drawing or
kind of like just farting around out in
the woods like on their property which
is actually quite large
and this hiker kind of turns up and he's
like man i am so lost like i parked out
on this on highway 209 and it's like i
thought i knew where i was going and the
gps [ __ ] me over or whatever and this
hiker is actually played by
you know the the kid's real dad john
adams who was also producer director you
know all that
so uh so yeah he's just kind of like uh
you know hey can you like tell me the
way back to the highway or what's going
on can i get some help or something like
that and she's like yeah i'm not allowed
to be around people and so she starts
backing away uh and then
i don't know if i would have spoiled
this or not what happens well like i
said you pretty much know that the mom
is a witch it can like do magical [ __ ]
so i will say though that she sees this
hiker dude and is like um
yeah i think i need to take care of this
situation because we don't want anybody
knowing like what's going on up here so
she takes care of the situation let's
say that
meanwhile izzy is just getting more and
more dissatisfied and doesn't understand
why her mom won't let her leave
now one thing that the hiker said to her
like before he was taken care of
was that um she's like oh i have a niece
i think it's a niece named amber and she
lives over that next mountain like you
should go to school with her and you
know izzy's like no i don't go to school
i'm homeschooled and she's like oh she's
about the same age as you so izzy
remembers this and so one day while her
mom's in town she decides she's going to
hike over there and see what's what lego
to the other mountain
so she actually does go over to the
other mountain and she's watching this
girl who's like sitting by this pool or
whatever
and she decides that she's gonna go over
there and befriend her
so that's sort of where
uh [ __ ] starts to go sideways as i said
i don't want to spoil too much about
this because it's a fairly new movie it
just came out last year and shutter just
added it not too long ago probably like
a couple months back i think they added
this one
um but yeah if you like
they're not okay so they're not exactly
witches they're kind of witches but
i don't know they're almost kind of like
d there's some demon [ __ ] as well it's
mostly witch but you know it's kind of
like a new well it's a new monster
basically um and it's called a
hellbender and but it's very very
similar to a witch the heart of the
story is pretty much as i said it's like
a coming-of-age story
but it's also
you know in the sense that it's this
daughter who
is kind of like learning to
grow up and like come into her own power
but she's also
rebelling against her mom who her mother
has been trying to protect her all this
time from her own power like fearing
that you know
just like witchcraft you can go either
way like good or evil so she like
doesn't want her daughter
succumbing to
uh you know this lust for power and like
becoming evil and stuff like that so
she's tried to protect her and so has
kept a lot of stuff from her
and so a lot of that is going on too
like where she's starting to question
maybe i should have told her all this
stuff earlier so she could have like
made her own decisions and stuff like
that so it's very much like that it's
basically i mean the where they shot
this i'm not entirely sure where they
should it looks like in the pacific
northwest or northern northern
california or something like that
somewhere but like the it's just
gorgeous like mountains and rocks and
streams and everything like that it's
really really beautiful
and it might be the same i wanted to say
that
i haven't seen the deeper you dig in a
while i think we watched that like a
year or two ago and it might be the same
house or the same place where they shot
it but now i don't know now that i'm
saying that maybe not but i'm kind of
thinking that maybe they shoot stuff
like right around where they live i'm
presuming so this is probably right like
right around where they live
but the cinematography is gorgeous and i
really really like
i mean it's it's low budget but honestly
i didn't really find the special effects
to be
i mean i thought they were pretty good
there's like some cgi in there like with
monster faces and stuff there's some
gore um you know with people getting
[ __ ] up and like you know guts and
blood and stuff like that so i don't
know i just thought it looked really
good and this was actually a pretty damn
good movie i really really enjoyed it i
love stuff about witchcraft and i just
really liked this sort of like unique
take on witchcraft and i really liked
the relationship between the mom and
daughter who like i said not only mom
and dad in the movie but their mom and
daughter in real life and i really do
love that this family
is just i just think that's so cool i
think that's so cool that
they know how to do everything like i
said they can direct they can edit they
can write music they can you know they
act and they just make these movies like
as a little collective oh and i forgot
to mention too that the girl that plays
amber like the friend that izzy goes to
like to find the friend that's zelda's
sister you know what i mean so there's
other family members in this too like
playing all the different parts like
family members and friends and i just
think that's so awesome that they just
like got together and they're like we're
gonna make movies and they're good and
it's just like it's really awesome so
i'm really really glad that they're
getting some uh attention because i
definitely think that independent
filmmakers like this should uh be
encouraged especially when the stuff
they're putting out is as good as this
i'm not sure if i liked this one or the
deeper you dig better um this one is
it has like some of the same visual
aesthetic to it like um
like when they're doing witchcraft for
example they'll be like these kind of
like flashing uh you know kind of [ __ ]
up imagery and stuff like that and that
was kind of going on in the deeper you
dig too but the deeper you dig was a lot
more surreal this one is a lot more
straightforward it's it's not really all
that complicated to figure out whereas
the deeper you dig was a lot more
ambiguous i don't know they both had
like some things to like recommend them
so it's kind of like they're similar but
they're very very different stories um
so they're both good and if you haven't
seen deeper you dig you should check
that one out too but definitely check
out hellbender it's on shutter right now
that might be the only place you can see
it i'm not entirely sure but definitely
check it out if you like witchcraft
movies and like i said you should
definitely support independent
filmmakers like this because it's just
really really cool that
we live in a time that that's you know
that that's possible for people to do
and i just think it's cool that they all
like they're all like a family and they
work together and make movies and that's
like really rad so anyway uh if you've
seen hellbender or if it sounds like a
good movie uh let me know your thoughts
about it in the comments and that will
do it for this flickers of fear i will
see you guys on the next one bye